[Music]
in president Trump's impeachment trial
senators swore to do impartial justice
how can they keep such an oath how can
parties and senators be impartial they
have to understand two things what's on
trial and what the Senate was created to
be first what is on trial president but
also the impeachment itself the
Constitution empowers the Senate to try
impeachments so the Senate must consider
not just factual questions but legal and
Prudential questions to second what was
the Senate created to be a counterweight
to both the house and the president
founders expected the Senate to embody a
mix of accountability and statesmanship
it's meant to temper the passions of the
house and passing laws and to play a
significant role in the president's
administration of domestic laws and
foreign policy on a Pietschmann trials
the Senate's ultimate opportunity to
serve both those roles and they are
needed most
that is the impartial justice that
impeachment calls upon them to do
impeachment does not need the Senators
to transform into jurors it needs
senators to become truly the Senate an
impeachment can the Senate and the house
be truly impartial let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like to see our scholars cover in
60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI